فوق تلال من الركام ينتظر وحيدا واستحاله
من الصدمه والالم انه من جنديرس البلده
المنكوبه اثر الزلزال المدمر
الدمار في كل مكان وناجون يتجرعون الام
فقدان عائلاتهم واقاربهم يحاولون استيعاب
حجم الخسائر الكبيره التي حلت بهم نحن
نبرك تحت هيك ما في اي مشكله بس اطفال
نساء
المصاب اللي طالعناه من تحت التراب يعني
ردود كذا هلق نزلت انا اولادي على المشفى
جسمه كله ازرق
على الارض تماما اكثر من الف بناء خارج
الخدمه لا يصلح للسكن انا 3900 عائله لا
تملك اي ماوى
في حقول بالقرب من المباني المدمره نصبت
بعض الخيام لايواء المنكوبين وقسم اخر
افترش ارضيه صاله رياضيه بانتظار اي
مساعدات قد تخفف من معاناتهم
عندي انا شهيد الحمد لله
وضعنا كتير تعبان
جنديرس هي المنطقه الاكثر كارثيه وتضررا
من الزلزال وفق التقارير وهو ما تعكسه
شكاوى ونداءات سكانها الذين يطالبون
بمساعدات عاجله تساعدهم على الصمود امام
الكارثه التي حلت بهم
وين المساعدات ملوك الشيخ العربيه